The Joe Rogan Experience December 18
2022 World Cup final you talk about the
the power the emotional power of sports
right my family and I were sitting and
watching the World Cup final and we had
uh the the extent to which we were
emotionally vested in Messi winning the
World Cup can only be it can only
demonstrate the beauty of sports right
because here's a guide that what we've
never met him
we're not Argentinian right right he
doesn't know that we're alive right and
yet it's life and death for us that he
should I mean it was so harrowing I
don't know if you watched the game that
at one point my son who's 11 years old
said I I can't watch this anymore I'm
going to have a heart attack uh that's
the the power of sports that it can pull
us in and it can make us truly try and
on my case before you before you
interject
it was kind of driven my desire for him
to win was driven by a really a purity
strand it was that it seemed cosmically
unjust for the greatest soccer player of
all time to not have won the World Cup
so when he won it to me it seemed like
the world is Right Beauty has won
I get it
look at that that's awesome and I should
add what a guy right humble
sweet family man what's fascinating to
me is as happy as they are the people on
the other team that were rooting for the
gym they're devastated right now yeah
that's that's the weird thing about
sports yeah you can get so attached to
what's happening that a loss is like
really a loss yeah can't believe we
[__] lost to Kansas City
well in in my first book ever 2007
evolutionary basic consumption I talk
about studies not my studies I was
citing other works that looked at what
happens to the testosterone levels of
fans as a function of whether their team
wins or loses of course
well it's fantastic uh you just take
salivary assays of fans as their team is
winning or losing you can get the
testosterone levels from that yeah yeah
that's interesting yeah and so now what
it's not surprising as you would know as
a as a fighter that if you and I fight
and you defeat me your testosterone
level goes up my testosterone level goes
down video game like a video game uh
except What's Happening Here is that
there is a vicarious endocrinological
response the fans are having the same
increases in their testosterone levels
or decreases as a function of their team
winning or not that's quite extra and
that shows you why it we become so
bonded to our favorite players and so on
we are really going through this battle
with them yeah that's it's really the
case with Fighters when people have a
fighter that they're really a giant fan
of and that person gets beaten a
devastating manner oh it's all
heartbreaking there's even Studies by
the way that have looked at what happens
to sexual behavior of fans after their
team wins or loses so if if let's say
you if your wife is upset that you're
not you haven't been producing in the
bedroom
she should pray that the husband's
favorite team wins because if he wins he
has an Inc increase in testosterone
level increases their libidden all drive
and so
we're animals
it's just
it's just attaching so much of your own
emotions to something completely out of
control and just rooting on it exactly
but do you know do you have a fan in any
sport where you've ever been that vested
in well there was one time I remember
when I was a kid
um I was a giant fan of Donald Curry
Donald Curry was the welterweight boxing
champion at the time
and he uh had a rivalry with this other
guy Milton McCrory and uh Donald Curry
knocked him out he became like my
favorite boxer and then Donald Curry he
got beat by this guy Lloyd hunt again it
was a devastating loss like people
couldn't believe Lloyd hunnigan beat
Donald Curry
and it was like Donald Curry might be on
the down slide but I was still like a
giant fan of his
and then Donald Curry fought Mike
McCallum and Mike McCallum hit him with
a left hook to the body and a left hook
to the chin and put him out
like out cold and I couldn't believe it
and I I ran here it is right here
I ran out of the house watch this boom
so that how cold the one with the black
shorts is your guy right the guy down
it's my guy okay
so I
I misremembered it wasn't a left hook to
the body it's like he goes with a right
hand and then a left hook behind it
but he just he ko'd ko'd Donald Curry
and I couldn't believe it and so I put
up my running shoes I couldn't stay home
I could I couldn't deal with it I
couldn't deal with it and I went running
in the snow
and I ran
right no one doesn't know the snow
I'm thinking about other stores another
time when someone lost I went running in
the snow I don't think it was in the
stock it was warm I don't I don't
remember but I remember I went running
and as I'm running and I'm running down
the road I'm thinking to myself I am
never gonna be this invested in someone
else winning or losing ever again right
I was so devastated that he lost what
what was the bond what what why why
technique his technique was perfect he
was crisp like he was coiled they called
him his his what was his nickname
something cobra
Here Comes Jamie
I forget what his nickname was
but his his technique was so crisp Lone
Star Cobra Lone Star Cobra there you go
he was out of Fort Worth
and his technique was so sharp I just
really I always admired guys who were
able to find like the shortest path to
connecting with a shot where it's just
like the technique is so dialed in yeah
there's guys that like Javonte Davis
like that their techniques so dialed in
that when you watch them uncork it's
like oh my God the efficiency of it the
way and so I was just a giant fan of the
guy I just loved as a person who like
really enjoyed technique I like watching
someone is exceptional at it I recently
put I don't remember a few months ago I
put out a sort of a hypothetical what if
scenario where I I think this was on
Twitter where I asked you know people
who follow me
would I be able to step on an NFL field
and under any circumstance simply get a
single yard as a running back right so
in other words right right so now for
example if I go into a boxing ring with
someone
the only way I'm going to survive is if
I keep running around long enough
because the singular time that they hit
me I'm unlikely to be able to withstand
that right so that's I'm gone right if I
play basketball I think I have enough
skills that I can receive the ball and
pass it off to someone right and so then
I started thinking what about other
sports
could the average person who doesn't
play that sport survive long enough to
do something I'm obviously not going to
get 100 yards but a single yard what are
your thoughts I I thought maybe I was
being presumptuous maybe an um I'm an
old guy but I thought that it could be
possible for the front line to make
enough of a hole for me to run through
for one year and I would just draw I
just need to get a single yard that's
possible and but a lot of people thought
there's no chance that that would happen
because they would catch you in the in
the backfield they would tackle you and
then you would die well they probably
could do that too that could happen as
well but if the defense is so strong
that they can just create a small enough
opening for you to go one yard I think
that's reasonable yeah it would suck for
you though dude they're gonna pile on
top of you you're never gonna be the
same especially since I've lost so much
weight at least before I looked like a
linebacker a fat linebacker yeah that
was you don't want that happening to you
what was that just happened there watch
watch again watch this guy this is the
running back trying to get the ball to
get one yard watch this
bam his helmet's off and he's hurt oh my
God oh my God he got attacked that's one
of five guys that are gonna try to stop
you from doing attack old these guys are
selling itself so Jamie is in the camp
of I'm not getting a single yard there's
a lot of well there's a lot of other
variables but it is possible that the
defense could have prevented that if the
defense is extraordinary and the guys
are on point and there's there's you
know games things happen right people
are trying to control things and people
are charging forward it's possible that
there's an opening just big enough for
anyone to get three yards right
or one yard rather three feet do you
think you could step on a soccer field
and look anything short of a complete
[__] no no impossible no I actually saw
you recently and I was really delighted
to hear that where you were
singing the Praises of how fit soccer
players oh my God we went to see the the
games here in Austin and when you watch
professionals first of all here's one
reason why soccer is problematic for
television they don't get breaks yeah so
there's no breaks like you know we'll be
right back with another word from
Nabisco you know there's none of that so
if you have commercials like you have to
interrupt the play of the game yeah and
then people have to catch up and then
it's not is it not live now or are you
gonna like have half of a commercial and
half of the game like what are you gonna
do yeah how are you gonna do that
because they don't stop they just keep
going and you have to be insanely fit
those guys look like thoroughbreds like
their legs were just [__] shredded so
there was a study a few years ago I
can't cite what it was but I looked at
who were the fittest athletes number one
was soccer that has to be you know what
number two was no squash players why I'm
guessing because there are a lot of
those very very quick accelerations that
you have to engage in to be able to get
the the ball is very dead right and so
you really have to have this incredible
quickness to be able to
so I'm not a weird thing for an elite
athlete to choose uh Jamie can we watch
I could describe squash
you know I tried to play it I got very
claustrophobic I'm being serious because
let me see what it looks like okay show
me a squash game it's like uh and it's
like a racquetball right no but with us
with a ball that's more dead racquetball
the ball has a lot more give
um it bounces more
I was just trying to look I found other
sports that sound like they would be
more but I didn't find it on a
scientific study my wife has been trying
to get me into pickleball what are what
are our thoughts about that
uh I hear people like it have I just
lost the no no come on man people like
pickleball
well apparently there's a whole craze of
pickleball now because it's not quite as
difficult as tennis you don't have to
cover as much ground it's still a racket
game it looks a lot of damage to the
knee so that's what I'm looking at right
there in terms of squash we're talking
you're running around yeah yeah a lot of
[__] explosive movements for old guys
like us yeah yeah best stick to yoga
pickleball you can play with a beer in
your hand so you should be all right
yeah pickleballs pickleball's the way to
go son